هذا وقال رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه هي اير
لبيد انه لن يتم التحقيق مع جنود الجيش
الايطالي من قبل مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدراليه الامريكيه ولا من قبل اي جهه
اجنبيه اخرى حتى وان كانت دوله صديقه اضفل
بعيد عن اسرائيل ارسلت احتجاجا شديدا لهجه
للجهات الامريكيه المختصه عقب اعلان وزاره
العدل الامريكيه فتحه تحقيق جنائيا في
اغتيال سبيله شيرين ابو عاقله
الجيش الاسرائيلي هو جيش اخلاقي وصاحبه
قيام جنود الجيش والضباط يحمون دوله
اسرائيل ويحققونها بشكل دقيق في كل حدث
استثنائي وملزمونها بقيام الديمقراطيه
وقوانينها لن يتم تحقيق مع جنود الجيش
الاسرائيليه على يد الاف بي اي ولا على يد
اي جهه اجنبيه مهما كانت تعتبر صديقه لان
نتخلى عن جنودنا لتحقيقات غريبه احتجاجنا
الحاد على ذلك ارسل للجانب الامريكي عبر
القنوات الملائمه